She was strange. One of the bitch. We had a guy again. Picture. Come back from Canada. Why bring. She was still.
The friend who are here. The other guy got off the train. Home. It's what. By the time I got there was two hours.
I was there I could see that was Gerry I never checked. My phrase. Yes. That. Anyway. But I came back. And.
Was like that doesn't matter. Makes you sound like what you do. Does a strike.
She is a natural right she spots I will not appear again that on his part he was a silly little joint.
And there was almost this tiny silence
when I thought I was good that it wasn't so much that the good looking guy was a new face
and your face group that all knew each other.
This was a guy and I signed on you not to say they were
and he was his new fries because I am in this corner that suddenly think that it was something.
They were looking at those doing this.
It was all done boilers the whole thing was a glance at last of those few seconds longer still there.
But that's as far as Little Guy one rushed me rushed into it as far as I would like to see straight. I said sure.
I was told it was a question. And I was actually at my place because all I was sign is him. He said.
I just couldn't believe that there were so many young any new fears I had seen so many times in one place once
and to never say never. And leave it. When that shot was my areas and she was terribly sympathetic.
And so I was great
and she makes me up so full of life draws looked like a shot until I got this to the bike up the tricky stuff trick.
Was the little.
They were getting It was one of the last of the let down of the things that it was just dreadful little bitch strange
carries that she lived across an alley where her living room bedroom window looks tried in the living room.
One of the papers is the time of the flight and she's trying to spoil what.
Yet she began the rush like her money selling this girl the type of tips that she had to tip madly in to be sure what
it was like there which obviously you can't assume for thought that it was a drink. You're out so she was never.
You know she was really trying to get something on him to roulette.
Which was nothing never even though they were there to see if the their stride was going all strong this time I was
alone but it was right up.
It was more than it was more offices where it's the offices of his drivers drivers lucky
and every room in the mine for her to go. This life with light is a real. To try to Woodlands of that very public site.
Here. Have the finest metal. Guy the guy.
Could see and even that was not actually my friend of mine it was Saturday morning show me what you got there.
Yeah there was a store any local places like the Red Sea ship just the way that you guys used to sit by the bar.
That still existed if she was sympathetic
but certainly had her fall guy that one's name that was there long before the race was the one.
Well yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Very quickly but that child was the guy who is just this is a long sixty's that was horrified that
when you had the wife if you didn't buy the bill they said she'll get three pack here. If you didn't know his wife.
I had to go to. The same what was the last from there.
But there were two of the Gulf Coast but they were Dutch like this is the paradox of East St The visual.
The court of strife a little facts a way to give these here
and there in the eyes of those who would be sitting in their shoes and Margaret
and she was understanding simplicity so vast a twit pic. It's a little. Actually that's your life. But who was the.
One thing. My. Right there in the church is doing. I'm giving you a new life reference to carry your day here.
On there that's not that's not the only one. Work on figuring. It is a city are not one. Cars. Every mile.
I want to say that if anybody did it.
You had a broad approach to do and get back to life and he was with only twenty six.
Let me read what he can lose back so that there is a different sixty three pretty.
And he's a very handsome which he will see the end of a trial run for their white for each of them. There.
If one of us got sick of this straight. It's strange because Charles de Gys and I just walked out of the system.
In the sixty's. He was shaking his hand was that attack. Of course because it was a fright or. Anyway.
It was a very harsh friendship and I was getting a lot of this and. It was the I was saying it was much more.
The old days that he came up.
One of the stories with the long standing in the bow look at the back of the heel somebody shoe
and if you saw a very foreign norm you saw a lot of this long drawn down the center of the back of the hill.
That was a guy. And he laughed and he told the story. Whatever sort to this day or this or that one. And this here.
I never saw read that there was one in the kind of which possibly was. Closest to the red. That the person thought.
But then you know where it was then because it was. It seems to be feeling what the big thing was he was.
And apparently everybody knew these kids at school we never knew it was well this is the fifty's the sixty's.
My friend of mine with their parents had their limits and got straight out of school. They never were possible.
The British set up here. They had the other one of the depicted in this very nicely. To go with the rights.
In his forty's.
And he's biased on what and I know you often but not to trip around
and he said places where you are night you guys live liars.
Is right in this respect was not just that I run the parish.
And he came up with this prize he set up in the path of the back here pushing back here is that for.
You never say never.
Is that any of the signals the station up to down except fire the view of Dr Carson just broader colors Ridge.
Where in casual flyers with the only way he didn't get the top and bottom line motherboard sure.
Chris not to show it wasn't a cane and it was White Castle. They want outside which was one of the material was Muslim.
Time was a very strong and it had a blast effect. And this is what I was very much. Seeing which I'm sure. It was.
Which. If you write.
It was very very amateurish you want physical we didn't go very far short of luck and he wanted to have a go.
And there was just priority here. Working or of livelihood living building that day it was originally electricity.
Many challenges minister I'd feel just as separate which is the city. And I took out of the building.
One of the in the head.
This is just a live shot office mean only one you manage to see how to connect to the fight to save lives that bosses
lunch.
And one dive with life it's like they are in the church where I was only back towards the very crowded so I think I had
the faintest idea that just there is no reason to measure and.
Anyway just taking the song to live the way out of that was right there. We died energy and that's it.
Yes it was tight. So there was a lark so I was wearing white snow white and on this beautiful sunny day to six.
I didn't get there but it led to the first shots I really feel that I would rather listen. To enjoy.
It just go along with that that little while I guess. I picked up. Very tight. Right there. And there was a try once.
Which was great. But I was enjoying. These rights. There. And. We picked up for their life one day.
That we were surprised the place. Just that she's.
And they were very friendly and down the time about what this was at the time on the side. But ya know. Actually there.
Look. They brought that up in the way this is the thing is with the letter they are fully aware that this.
Mary would have been court.
Which can give me cameras that were just for me to give evidence against the first victim
and this is what went to the Christmas tree back to the court in the act.
Somehow or other privacy or most blacked out of the Black their date is it's a very cloudy.
If you're there that it's very difficult there for how they got themselves it was it so that she could go
or rather what it was those telling the story. Like the civilian crew it was.
And they had no American officer really Mauritania.
And there finished up in front of the British doctor who took horrible exception to this
and beat them with a carrier is this we have with this character not as a stick.
And he lost his temper at the it's just. It's very well written. That it's just horrible. Yes.
This man is the law of their story. I think very rightly that's the legislative precept of a different way. To feel.
He was in this to do this to this child. Not sure what it was that they are. And the chaplain has only offices.
But if they still effect all his life for a while then he was in disgrace. Which was just.
He got caught and he was given the full military tree Court-Martial open and drummed out
and drowned out his very dramatic ration that's literally what the entire station which lasted in front of their toilet
through your hands of me.
Drums were literally rolled and the commanding officer read out the child read out the findings of the four March
and the sentence which was to be discharged dishonorably from the service or stripped of all right.
Which point he goes for added to.
This is why there was such an eye out for him which is always been a strong and he was right all right.
As a result of his volunteer. State for what they were getting off the court and I go on to the fore.
Yes but that's the way. That they're on. Guys who want to market for others that are there for nearly every guy so.
For us. It's that. Has nothing on it. That's the way to get the records.
That would be quite interesting for you guys of the night he had. Just pretty things that you like.
As long as you pointed out strongly that you had the right. And that you got something out.
He was afraid you were clear. But did the other thing. And you touched on it.
We're coming back to early to tell the story. But I think that probably exists here.
And it's a very difficult one but do you think that. What's this with the sort of sexual behavior.
Has changed in the sense I mean it's always had a reputation of a hit experience that might be true to anything.
But well I didn't really want to write your. I ended up with a very short but. No I think the right.
That is the right thing that I think just because I was the person.
Why you had to get out because because of the first couple Americans.
This kind of compatibility through that process what did you want to turn it off work. Very very. Personal. Story.
Just that. He just could not do anything else.
I think that between my legs
and it was thirty three joining us with a very bright twenty six years ago the right stuff to reject that rejected him
because he couldn't.